what do you recommend men check for to
optimize their hormones well i think
every man after 40 probably even before
40 should have
a total testosterone and a free
testosterone test done so it's really
important that you get the free
testosterone test done because
your total testosterone is mostly bound
and because it's bound it's actually not
free it's not available to the tissues
so when you ask your doctor you know to
check your hormones you definitely want
to ask them to not only just get a total
but also get um a free because the free
is going to be
the one that's going to tell you you
know how much testosterone is actually
active in your tissues and it's not
bound up
but that's a really good place um
to start you know a uh yeah tsh is
always great too you know uh which tests
for your thyroid um i tend to test for
three for a free t3 and a free t4 as
well just to make sure that those
hormones are optimized so those are part
of the
thyroid hormone so generally speaking
the medications given for thyroid
replacement
is level thyroxine so that's like a pure
t4 and now your t4 does get converted to
t3 so you know a lot of people just take
um t4 itself
but every now and then
you do get a patient who uh you know
doesn't get a good conversion of t4 to
t3 and those and those so for those
patients you may need to use something
called a desiccated thyroid which has a
little bit of t3 in it and then you know
patients can kind of um you know get uh
be treated that way um and then just
coming back to the um testosterone so
generally speaking i offer patients a
couple different options the biggest
ones are um injections and creams
so when you have the injection um you
know the benefit of that is that you're
only doing it twice a week generally um
so you know i shouldn't just mention one
thing on that like on testosterone even
right on the bottle like it'll say
like 200 milligrams every two weeks
which is ridiculous because you know
you're gonna feel like superman for two
or three days and then it's gonna level
off and that last week you're basically
gonna feel like [ __ ] so now you really
need to uh try to you know
minimize the the highs and lows
so i find that uh and i find even if
you're giving it you know once a week
versus two times a week i mean it's
still it's a lot better but it's still
not perfect so i actually find you know
injecting it twice a week
intramuscularly is is uh is a good way
to do it um and most patients that
i see will use somewhere between 50 to
70 micrograms of dough so usually
between 100 to 140 micrograms a week
usually 120 is a really good dose for it
for most men in terms of
optimizing their testosterones but not
not not pushing it like out of range
um but the second option to with regards
to uh treating is um cream so you can
get compounded creams you can get just
the like the generic like andrew gel
cream and then that can be put on daily
and so because it's put on daily then
you're getting a very very even dose um
the only thing with that is that it does
have to be put on daily so people do you
know sometimes forget um the other thing
is i mean it's very very minimal it's
overblown like
for the most part but there is some uh
you know chance that you could transfer
to someone else if you put it on your
arm and then you hug someone else or
that kind of thing so you know i find
that a lot of patients who have like
young kids are really really
apprehensive about using it for that
reason yeah and then it's just like yeah
yeah and then it's just like
inconvenient if you want to you know
like get a shower jump into a pool after
whatever you know so um those are
generally the the different options for
um for men
how
frequent like do you all meant does
testosterone lower for all men after 40
or other dietary things you can do to
increase it or is it just gonna hit
everybody
so it definitely starts to decrease um
actually even by like 27 or 28 you'll
start to know it'll it'll start to
decrease slightly and then by 40.
so it's not just women it's not just
winning
that just went but um and i'll get back
to that in a second just on that note
for women uh also have testosterone just
like men do and um
that's where a woman's sex drive comes
from as well you know it's from uh
testosterone and you know i do have some
women who take a low dose of
testosterone not only just for their sex
drive but also just for um their general
energy and motivation and kind of just
sounds kind of fun
it's going to increase yeah make you a
little more
argumentative yeah
yeah and probably a little bit just more
like general confidence i guess you
could say and then if you have more it's
wonderful you'd probably be uh you know
sounds like you're gonna want some